Did I mention Towa-chan, the current queen? She does
n't seem like a good girl. She seems to have settled into the
judo club well, and I
think she'll be perfect as an yorishiro soon. She's Towa-chan's second child, and she's about the
age after that.  I
guess that's what you were trying to do. I didn't think it was a formal contract,
but you're
causing trouble for your subordinates and
forcing them into a situation where they have no choice but to use the tiara. Why are you trying to insult me?  That's fine.
If you withdraw from the Republic, I'll leave you alone.
Why do I have to do what you say?
I'm an
individual, so what's
polite about it? [
Music]
Force, etc.  I don't like that barbaric act,
but if you're
told to do something, do it.Besides, I
've always thought you were annoying, right?I
guess we both agree.